let's talk about benign prostatic
hyperplasia what does hyperplasia mean
it means enlargement okay so this BPH
problem is basically an enlarged
prostate it affects your urination the
stream of your urine is a bit on the
weak side you might find that you
dribble after you urinate and you just
might have the Sensation that your
bladder is not empty so we're going to
talk about this and there's actually
this one drink that you can consume
every day to help you shrink the
prostate but more important than the
remedy is to understand the mechanism
and how you develop this problem in the
first place a lot of men as they get
older develop this condition and some
even develop prostate cancer so this
video is going to cover both topics so
basically you have this prostate
that is just underneath your urinary
bladder and there's a little tube that
comes out of the urinary bladder okay
that's called the urethra and the
prostate wraps around that and normally
it should be small but when it enlarges
it becomes bigger and it can constrict
the little tube that allows urine to
flow and even become so big it can push
up into the urinary bladder decreasing
the volume of your urinary bladder so
you really don't have the full capacity
to hold urine all of the estrogen that
women have and that men have
actually originate from testosterone so
estrogen is a byproduct of testosterone
and the convert testosterone to estrogen
you need this enzyme called aromatase
and aromatase is made by the testicle as
well as your fat cells so that's number
one of this Foundation number two excess
estrogen
increases the size of the prostate
that's interesting because you probably
thought that your problem was too much
testosterone but if that's true then why
does testosterone decrease with age in
men estrogen increases with age and like
I said before estrogen is an anabolic
hormone it makes things get bigger
here's another little uh thing
intraprostatic estrogen levels that
means the estrogen within the prostate
is not dependent on the estrogen in the
blood so you can't really figure out how
much estrogen you have in the prostate
by measuring the levels in your blood
estrogen also increases another hormone
called prolactin that can also increase
the size of the prostate phytoestrogens
certain phytochemicals in plants
can mimic estrogen but
not very strongly in fact very weakly so
if we look at human estrogen compared to
plant estrogen plant estrogen is
basically about 10 000 to a hundred and
forty thousand times less strong so this
is why sometimes people are confused
when they're eating certain plants and
herbs that might increase estrogen it's
a very very very tiny amount and so
you're never going to have to worry
about becoming estrogen dominant if you
consume any of these plant-based
estrogen compounds and I'm really
talking about the
phytoestrogens in
pumpkin seeds and saw palmetto and even
certain types of soy of course if you're
going to do soy you have to really make
sure it's always organic because most of
the soy is GMO but the remedy that I'm
going to recommend for the prostate is
not any one of those what I'm going to
recommend is we focus on inhibiting that
enzyme that I mentioned remember we
talked about testosterone turning into
estrogen okay with help of that enzyme
called aromatase what we want to do is
we want to inhibit that enzyme naturally
if you can inhibit that enzyme you'll
have less production of estrogen and
hopefully you can shrink the prostate
now the first thing to know is how does
this enzyme increase okay because it
does increase with age unfortunately and
also it can increase with body fat this
is why losing weight is an important
thing it can increase with insulin I've
talked a lot about that topic in fact if
you're on keto you're going to be a lot
better off because you're then going
they decrease the enzyme directly by
reducing insulin this is why even
diabetics or people that do high carb
diets have a big problem with the
prostate now another thing that
increases this enzyme alcohol I'm sorry
it does alcohol is definitely a factor
it can actually just make more estrogen
in your body another one is whole grains
so-called healthy foods that they say
you should be consuming and then you
also have hormone replacement therapy or
birth control pills which you just need
to know that like estrogen can also
increase that enzyme what will decrease
that enzyme this is the most important
thing you need to know from this whole
video number one regular consumption of
cruciferous vegetables like kale
broccoli cabbage arugula all of the
cruciferous have the capacity of
decreasing that enzyme helping you
regulate this extra bit of estrogen that
you have another thing that will help
you is white button mushrooms make sure
you saute them don't eat them raw
because you don't get the effect if you
have it raw flaxseed which I know some
people are concerned it's going to
increase your estrogen it's not going to
but if you you've heard conflicting
information
you have two choices you can actually
read the studies down below or just just
omit that remedy altogether because it's
not the most powerful one another remedy
would be green tea but the biggest
remedy I'm going to recommend okay and
I'm going to put the links down below is
citrus peel okay the peelings of lemon
apparently there are some really
interesting things in lemon peel that
not only inhibit that enzyme aromatase
but will perform all sorts of other
benefits for not just the prostate but
for the whole body there's actually five
times more nutrition in that peel than
the actual juice so in addition to
losing weight with healthy keto reducing
the insulin consuming cruciferous
vegetables
all you need to do you can do this at
any time of the day take a whole lemon
okay put it in the blender
the glass of water okay and then blend
it make it all nice and creamy maybe
blend it for 30 seconds and you can also
then add about five to ten drops of
liquid Stevia okay to sweeten it or you
can add one half to one cup of
blueberries which also support the
prostate as well you can blend all that
together and drink it as a shake either
with or without the blueberries the
lemon peel is the most important because
we're trying to reduce that aromatase so
we can reduce the estrogen and keep
these ratios of higher testosterone or
normal testosterone to lower estrogen so
out of anything you can do those are the
most important steps now there's some
other really cool benefits with lemon
peels then if you haven't seen this
video you must watch it I put it up
right here